Durch das hohe Privileg und die besondere
Ehre von Ravenna, Ihnen den
Präsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten vorzustellen, war es
nie besser, den
amerikanischen Traum zu leben,
wenn Sie hart arbeiten, wenn Sie an sich glauben,
wenn Sie an Amerika glauben, dann können
Sie alles träumen  Sie können
alles sein und zusammen können wir
absolut alles erreichen
[Applaus]
temperierte Reden, da ich denke, dass
die Bärenart nichts mehr hergibt
[Musik],
also fangen wir heute Abend damit an, anzuerkennen,
dass der Zustand unserer Union stark ist,
weil unser Volk wirklich stark ist  Ich
würde sagen, und zusammen bauen wir ein
sicheres, starkes und stolzes Amerika auf, so weit, so
gut. Ich meine, es geht ihm schlecht. Ich dachte, er würde es tun. Es
gibt einige Dinge, die ich mag
Die
Vorschriften der Obama-Ära Ich mag es nicht, wie
er die Weltdrogen verdoppelt Ich
mag es nicht, wie er Jeff-Sessions anwendet,
sind ziemlich offen Ich denke, Jeffs
Subhash ist
über die letzten Jahre  Ohr, die Welt hat gesehen,
was wir immer wissen, dass keine Menschen auf der
Erde so furchtlos oder mutig oder
entschlossen sind wie die Amerikaner
[Musik]
es ist eine veraltete Tradition Ich meine, es sind
nur ein Haufen aufgeblähter Stipendiaten,
die sich mit wem in
Capitol Hill fotografieren lassen
[  Beifall]